hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse Orion comm and in this video we're
going to go over how to check a carotid
pulse in my previous video we went over
how to check a radial pulse and today
we're going to go over checking your
carotid typically these are the two
commonly used sites when checking a
pulse rate on yourself or on a patient
and what we're going to do is I'm going
to demonstrate how to check it on
yourself and then on a person so let's
get started the very first thing you
want to do is you want to use your index
and your middle finger do not use your
thumb because your thumb has a pulse and
whenever you feel on another person you
would be counting your own pulse rate so
use these two fingers then you're going
to sort of lift your head up and find
your windpipe which is right here and
then there's a muscle right beside of
your windpipe and you can check your
carotid on either side and you're going
to feel in that crevice between that
muscle and the windpipe and apply light
pressure and you should feel a little
pulsation when you are filling this
pulsation make sure you note two things
the rhythm is it regular or irregular
and how strong is it is it weak is it
faint is it strong average or bounding
very important things you want to know
because you'll be charting this as a
nurse then if it's regular you're going
to count your you're going to count the
pulsation for 30 seconds while timing
yourself on a watch so killing for 30
seconds whatever number you get multiply
that by two and you do this if the pulse
is regular if the pulse is irregular you
would count it for one full minute and
that's your pulse rate now let's
demonstrate how to check a pulse rate
and a carotid on a person okay when
you're checking your crowded pulse
you'll get on whatever side of the
patient remember you can fill crowded
pulse on the left or the right side and
I am on his left side so I'm going to
fill with my left hand and I'm going to
find the windpipe and usually men have
Adam's apples so it's really easy to
find and then you're going to find the
muscle of the neck which is about and
this
region and then you're going to feel
with your index and your middle finger
rot in between that crevice area and you
should feel a pulsation and I'm noting
the rhythm and his rhythm is regular and
then I'm noting the strength and it's
strong now since it's regular I'm going
to count it for 30 seconds and multiply
that by two so let's count for 30
seconds okay I got 30 so I'm going to
take 30 and multiply that by 2 30 times
2 is 60 so that is his heart rate and
whenever I document I'll put 60 it was
strong and it was regular so that is how
you check a carotid pulse thank you so
much for watching this video and please
subscribe to my youtube channel